whew in China have felt the economic
impact of the coronavirus as much as
migrant workers who Yong Chi is a day
laborer who usually works on
construction sites but the building
sector took a hit from the corona virus
outbreak finding a job is harder now
than it was there are more protective
regulations like social distancing rules
but we have survived the worst months of
the pandemic at private job centers
postings on the windows show how much
the job market has taken a hit wages are
declining the equivalent of around 20 US
dollars per day instead of 30 but who
young she says he doesn't want to
criticize China in front of the
international media she Unni is one of
the few people in China willing to speak
out
he's a human rights lawyer and
authorities have been watching him more
closely since the pandemic began when
many Chinese took to social media to
call for freedom of speech he
participated by signing a petition the
police told me that if I didn't
cooperate with them and delete what I
had written if I continued to speak my
mind there would be consequences for my
family and me so how did you walk she
and II worries that the government will
use the pandemic to tighten its control
over Chinese citizens a number of
journalists have already felt the
pressure lead say hua was a news anchor
for state-controlled media when the
pandemic hit he quit his job to report
independently from Wuhan
a classified ad called for nightshift
workers at a funeral home Lee took the
job hoping to find out the true number
of people in Wuhan who had succumbed to
the virus he was broadcasting live when
plainclothes police entered his
apartment and arrested him he
disappeared for two months
alcohol in April he appeared in a single
video explaining that he was simply in
quarantine many of his viewers say he
had been forced to lie
China's critics say state propaganda has
been ramped up since the pandemic began
state TV portrays China as a global
Saviour
sending health care supplies by the ton
to countries in need national pride is
on the rise
China's handling of the crisis has been
a model for the world that's the opinion
of many here at the great wall this is
how China works first our leaders come
up with a plan and the people should
follow without raising too many
objections it benefits everyone here you
see the difference between socialism and
capitalism you should probably take a
lesson from China China believed it had
the corona virus pandemic under control
the economy was once again up and
running but a new outbreak threatens to
draw the country back into a crisis
let's bring in our correspondent Matias
building in Beijing for more on this
good day to you Matias a China saying
that the latest outbreak is under
control in the capital and that
infection rates will be lowering again
in the next few days how credible are
these reports from the government
well as if you remember the first
outbreak and do you remember how they
were struggling to bring it under
control at the first sight it's really
surprising that after a few days they
say okay now we know everything that's
happening on the ground and just wait
you will see in the next few days
whether that the numbers will decline
what is different now is that they are
able to test a lot more people so they
might be able to get a quicker picture
of the whole thing within a shorter
period but of course they haven't tested
anybody they are confident right now
that it's not hasn't spread beyond the
the the the surroundings of this market
and the people who are directly linked
to this market we still need to wait and
see they also said the same thing about
Rohan they're in a better position now
to make this assessment but when the
numbers decline we will see the numbers
declining until then these are just
words but see you said I'd like to talk
about what we what we were covering in
our report Beijing's messaging during
this crisis in our report we see a
China's presenting itself as exporting
the best practices to the entire world
for containing the virus how much is
this messaging tied to the international
pressure Beijing's facing facing to open
up for an independent investigation into
the initial outbreak in Wuhan yes
Beijing has faced a lot of criticism for
its initial handling of the crisis
domestically and internationally and the
fact that they were able until recently
to bring the numbers down was a key
pillar of their strategy of defense they
will not allow an independent
investigation that they do not control
themselves that they've made this clear
and it's totally beyond what Beijing has
ever done Beijing has never allowed
external people to assess what is
happening in the country so it's very
important for them to maintain this
image that they are under control and
that's why it's very critical to them to
bring these numbers down quickly here in
Beijing to show that they are under
control to show this to the Internet
community so they can point to other
countries and say look how badly they
are dealing with it look and look how we
are dealing with it this is important
for the international defense but it's
also important for people here in China
this is how the government justifies
what it's done this is how the
government is trying to make people
forget what happened at the beginning
and it to a certain extent it is working
I hear from time to time just just
recently just half an hour ago somebody
told me again well you should be glad
that you're in China right now and not
in Europe because here at least the
government is taking control of things
so bringing down these numbers is what
they need to do now if they want to keep
their if they want to keep this under
control
mattias billing her thanks very much for
that from Beijing